off did you did you how did you did you
get along with those women because they
look pissed and actually oh wait Eli
tweeted did you see it did you see what
I tweeted back Eli tweeted I don't know
if you have that in the copy I saw it no
I didn't see the feedback but this is
what Eli this is a I keep saying it
because I'm going to it's a biological
man trans woman says ready to get heated
I joined at Vice news for a debate panel
on feminism it's not helpful to platform
fascists like Vice did this talking
about you about a fashion it's a harsh
accusation but I figured the least I
could do is prevent the anti-feminism
from spreading even more disinformation
there's that word they love oh somebody
they disagree with that hurt their
feelings this information what did you
Tweet back I didn't oh I tweeted
aren't you a predator or am I tripping
no no I'm gonna be honest he could be he
could I'm just saying you're gonna call
me a fascist yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
point out that